WE'RE OPENING THE
BEGINNING OF SEVEN ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC SAFETY ARE
WE WILL BEGIN AS A SUB
COMMITTEE- UNTIL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS GET HERE AND WE DIDN'T
WANT TO HOLD UP MEMBERS WHO ARE
HERE ON TIME- TO BEGIN SO I
BELIEVE MISTER RODRIGUEZ
DISPERSED. AB. ONE NINE THREE
SIX NINETEEN THIRTY SIX PRICE
GOUGING PUBLIC SAFETY POWER
CUTOFFS. WHENEVER YOU'RE READY
MYSTERY BUT THREE GUESS. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY PRESENT
A. B. NINETEEN THIRTY SIX I
WANT TO BEGIN BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS AND THANK
THE CHAIRMAN STAFF FOR WORKING
WITH ME ON THOSE AND OTHER
AMENDMENTS. LAST YEAR MILLIONS
OF CALIFORNIANS EXPERIENCE
NUMEROUS WIDESPREAD A LATE THE
DESTRUCTION OF ELECTRICITY
SERVICE DUE TO PUBLIC SAFETY
POWER SHUT OFFS PS PS BY
UTILITY. ELECTRIC UTILITY
PROVIDERS. FOR MANY PS PS
EVENTS WHERE THE ONLY GIVEN A
FEW DAYS NOTICE OF A SCHEDULE
OUTAGE CAUSING THEM TO QUICKLY
SEEK OUT AND PURCHASE THE
CENTRAL GOODS NEEDED. UNDER THE
EVENT. AS WE HAVE SEEN ALREADY
PS PS. EVENTS BECAUSE A SURGEON
AMOUNT OF ESSENTIAL GOODS AND
THE FEW DAYS BEFORE AN OUTAGE.
THIS SURGE. IN DEMAND GREAT
OPPORTUNITY FOR SOME SELLER TO
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF CONSUMERS BUY
PROSCAR ALLERGY THE COST OF
GOODS SUCH AS GENERATORS
GASOLINE AND MEDICAL SUPPLIES.
WHILE MOST SALES WOULD TAKE
PLACE AS NORMAL WE KNOW THAT
PEOPLE CAUGHT IN DIRE
CIRCUMSTANCES BECOME VULNERABLE
TARGETS. AND ARE UNLIKELY TO
REALIZE THEY HAVE BEEN TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF. PS PS EVENTS ARE
EXPECTED TO BE THE NEW NORMAL
IN THE NEXT TEN YEARS WHICH ONE
PRESENTING THIS BILL TODAY. A.
B. NINETEEN THIRTY SIX IS A
PROACTIVE MEASURE NOT A
REACTIVE ONE THAT WILL PROVIDE
PROTECTION FOR CALIFORNIANS.
FROM PRICE GOUGING DURING P. S.
P. S. EVENTS BEFORE IT FOR
TWENTY OCCURS WITH ME TO
TESTIFY TODAY JOHN KENNEDY WITH
THE ROLE COUNTY REPRESENT US
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU MISTER
KENNEDY GOOD MORNING JOHN
KENNEDY WITH RC RC REPRESENT
THIRTY SEVEN WORLD COUNTIES
WE'VE BEEN HIT ARD BY THE P.
S. P. ASSISTANCE. WE SUPPORT A.
B. NINETEEN THIRTY SIX BECAUSE
WE THINK A PROVIDE SOME
CLARIFICATIONS THE PS PIA.
AMOUNTS ARE SUBJECT TO THE
PRICE GOUGING PROTECTIONS- WE
HAVE A COUPLE LOCAL COUNTIES
THAT HAVE ALREADY ADOPTED
ORDINANCES- IMPOSING PRICE
GOUGING PROTECTIONS FOR THEIR
RESIDENTS- WE THINK THE PIECES
TO ADD GENERATORS- AND TO ADD
MEDICAL DEVICES IS ESPECIALLY
IMPORTANT. ONE TO PROTECT
CRITICAL FACILITIES AND
INFRASTRUCTURE OPERATED
OFTENTIMES BY A LOT OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. AND THEN TO
PROTECT THE ACCESS AND
FUNCTIONAL NEEDS POPULATION
THOSE WHO HAVE MEDICAL
DISABILITIES THAT REQUIRE-
DURABLE MEDICAL EQUIPMENT TO
SUPPORT TO THEIR THEIR LIVES-
THAT BEING SAID- WITH RESPECT
TO THE COMMITMENTS THAT ARE
BEING ADOPTED TODAY TO. REMOVE
THE PROVISIONS FOR HOTELS AND
MOTELS WE WANT TO MAKE ABUNDANT
CLEAR THAT THAT IS NOT. IT AT
MOVING SOME OF THE TOOLS FROM
THE LOCAL TOOL BOX TODAY AND
THAT WE CAN STILL ADOPT
ORDINANCE THAT ARE MORE
RESTRICTIVE PURSUANT. TO THE
TEXT J. THERE ARE MORE STRICT
THE STATE. TELLS COMMUNITIES
THESE ARE A TIME INDIVIDUALS
WHO NEED TWENTY FOUR HOUR
ELECTRICITY AND HOTELS AND
MOTELS AND ENERGIZED AREAS
MIGHT BE ONE OF THE FEW PLACES
THEY CAN GO TO HAVE ELECTRICITY
SO WE WANT TO RETAIN
PROTECTIONS FOR TEN LOCAL%
PROTECTION SO THAT WE CAN GUARD
AGAINST PRICE GOUGING WE'VE
SEEN SOME INSTANCES IN THE BAY
AREA WHERE- PRICES WENT UP FOR
AT LEAST ONE HOTEL FROM TWO
HUNDRED DOLLARS AND I TO TWELVE
HUNDRED TONIGHT SO AND WHAT
ABOUT IT LIKE THAT WERE NOT
CORRECTING THOSE LOCAL
AUTHORITY. THEY WILL REMAIN SO
WE LOOK TO CONTINUING TO WITH
THE AUTHOR AND WORK WITH THE
COMMITTEE- TO MAKE SURE THAT
IS. THAT UNDERSTANDING- STANCE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT. ONE MISTER MEMBERS
RYAN SHERMAN WITH THE RIVERSIDE
SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION- WE'VE
BEEN ADVERSELY IMPACTED BY THE
SHOPS AS WELL AND WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT BILL THANK YOU THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS IS SHOWN MUCH LEARN THE
OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
KERR CHILD DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA WHERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. MORNING MY
NAME IS JULIE A HOME AT THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WATER
AGENCIES WERE ACTUALLY A
SUPPORT AND CONCEPT RIGHT NOW
WE APPRECIATE THE ADDITION OF
GENERATORS AND THE DIFFERENT
TYPES OF FUEL FOR GENERATORS-
BUT WE WANT WE ARE HOPING TO
SEE SOME EXPANSION TO INCLUDE
AN- TO REPAIR AND PARTS BECAUSE
THESE THINGS DO FAIL DURING
THESE- DURING THESE EVENTS. AND
SO WE REALLY APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR'S EFFORT TO ADDRESS ONE
OF THE UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES
OF PS PS WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH EVERYBODY ON THAT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. ANYONE
IN OPPOSITION GOING TWICE THREE
TIMES SEEING NONE WILL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ANY QUESTIONS.
THERE'S NOT AND YOU MAY.
INCLUDE THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS
ARE STRUCK LAST RIVAL BANK. BUT
SOON AS SOON AS WE HAVE A
QUORUM WE'LL TAKE THE BILL UP
FOR A VOTE ON THE CHAIRS
RECOMMENDED I VOTE ALLEN AT
THANK YOU PERSONALLY FOR-
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS AND I
A NO AS A FORMER EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS COORDINATOR I KNOW
HOW IMPORTANT THIS IS- AND
HOPEFULLY AS YOU MOVE FORWARD-
HOPEFULLY GET A QUORUM TO
REMOVE FORD. THIS ONE IS TIMES
OUT I NEED I NEED A REPUBLICAN
SO. THIS SO WE CAN MOVE FOR.
EVERYONE WE CAN GET THIS OUT SO
THANK YOU MISTER DO YOU THINK.
MR MAIENSCHEIN. MORNING MR
CHAIR YES WHO. I THE ITEM
NUMBER FOUR AB TWENTY FOURTEEN
MAIENSCHEIN MEDICAL MISCONDUCT
MISUSE OF. BERMAN OVER N. OR
EMBRYOS IF I DON'T GET ENOUGH
REPUBLICANS YOU HAVE TO SWITCH
BACK. I CAN'T I CAN'T HELP YOU
THERE. SO AT THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS FERTILITY
FRAUD OCCURS WHEN A DOCTOR THAT
SPECIALIZES IN ASSISTED
REPRODUCTIVE MEDICINE KNOWINGLY
IMPLANTS A PATIENT WITH A SPERM
SAMPLE THAT IS NOT THE ONE
SELECTED FROM THE DONOR BANK
BUT INSTEAD IS FROM THE DOCTOR
ITSELF- IT IS CRAZY. I MEAN I
IT'S NOT SAID THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT WERE EVEN HAVING TO.
CONSIDER BUT IN TWENTY FIFTEEN
IN INDIANAPOLIS POSITION WAS
FOUND OF USED HIS OWN SAMPLE TO
INSEMINATE AT LEAST FIFTY
PATIENTS. ARE ALL WITHOUT THEIR
CONSENT IN TWENTY NINETEEN A
TEXAS WOMAN APPROACH THE
LEGISLATURE LEGISLATURE AFTER
DISCOVERING HER MOTHER WAS
UNKNOWINGLY INSEMINATED WITH
HER DOCTOR SAMPLE INSTEAD OF
THE SAMPLE FROM A DONOR SHE
SELECTED NEARLY. THIRTY YEARS
PRIOR. THANKFULLY CALIFORNIA
DOES HAVE LAWS AGAINST THESE
PRACTICES HOWEVER THERE IS A
GLARING DEFICIENCY AND CURRENT
LAW CALIFORNIA'S CURRENT
STATUTE HAS A STATUE OF
LIMITATIONS WHICH PROVIDES A
THREE YEAR WINDOW AFTER
COMMISSION OF THE OFFENSE. FOR
PROSECUTORS TO PURSUE ACTIONS
IN THE TWO CASES THAT WERE-
THAT I JUST MENTIONED VICTIMS
WERE MADE AWARE THEIR CASES
DECADES LATER AS A RESULT OF
AVAILABLE GENETIC DNA TESTING.
UNDER CURRENT LAW THESE VICTIMS
WOULD BE UNABLE TO SEEK
RECOURSE AND THE PERPETRATORS
WOULD POTENTIALLY ESCAPE
PROSECUTION AB TWENTY FOURTEEN
WOULD CHANGE THE STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS ON FERTILITY FRAUD
RELATED CRIMES. TO ONE YEAR
FROM DISCOVERY THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN IPO.
THANK YOU. DO YOU HAVE ANY
OTHER WITNESSES. NOW. ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. SEEN
NONE OF ANY QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBER. THANK THIS
REGION I JUST WANNA THANK YOU
FOR THAT THIS WASN'T A CRIME I
WAS AWARE OF UNTIL I READ YOUR
BILL BUT- IT FEELS LIKE ONE OF.
THE LARGEST VIOLATIONS THAT CAN
HAPPEN TO A WOMAN SO I
APPRECIATE YOUR PAYING
ATTENTION TO THIS AND OBVIOUSLY
THIS IS THE CHANGES NEEDED AND
I LOOK FORWARD TO SUPPORTING
IT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISS
PARKER. UP AND YOU MAY CONCLUDE
MASSAGE THANK YOU VERY MUCH AT
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. YESTERDAY IT TOO IS A
CRIME I. DID NO FUN THANK YOU
AND IT COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING IT TO OUR ATTENTION TO
JEFF. ONCE WE GET A QUORUM WILL
RECOMMENDED AYE VOTE AND-
BEFORE YOU GET OUT OF HERE
TODAY THANK. THANK YOU MICHELLE
THANK YOU. A POWER. FOR THAT
BERNARD FORBATH. JOSH YOUR
BURNER ASSEMBLY MEMBER TASHA.
I
AM. A MISSILE MON. COULD YOU
PLEASE JOIN US AB TWENTY SIXTY
ONE SIR WE COULD GET THROUGH
THIS AGENDA FAIRLY QUICKLY.
AFTER THE WORD. WE HIS MISS LOW
MOAN. NOW PRESENTING OF MISSILE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LIMON AB TWENTY
SIXTY ONE UP BY ARMS
INSPECTIONS THANK YOU TERRY
MEMBERS AND THANK YOU ALL FOR
YOUR PATIENCE I WANTED TO START
BY ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
SIXTY ONE ENSURES THAT ALL
VENDORS A CALIFORNIA GUN SHOWS
ARE SUBJECT TO INSPECTION
AUTHORITY OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE. LAW ALLOWS DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE TO INSPECT THE
RECORDS OF SOME FIREARM DEALERS
AND AMMUNITION VENDORS AYE. BUT
NOT ALL. NEW BREED FOR EXAMPLE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE LACKS
INSPECTION AUTHORITY OVER
VENDORS WHO HOLDS FEDERAL
FIREARM LICENSES BUT ARE NOT
REQUIRED TO OBTAIN CALIFORNIA
LICENSES CLOSING THIS LOOPHOLE
IS IMPORTANT TO ENSURE THAT ALL
FIREARMS. AND AMMUNITION
VENDORS CONDUCTING BUSINESS IN
CALIFORNIA ARE ABIDING BY THE
SAME RULES I HAVE WITH ME TODAY
ASHLEY IRIS FROM THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THANK
YOU TERRY MY NAME IS ASHLEY
YEARS APART ON BEHALF OF PUBLIC
PART BUT JUSTICE. COULD YOU
MOVE THE MICHAEL CLOSEST
ATTORNEY GENERAL WOULD LIKE TO
THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER LAMONT
FOR OFFERING THE BILL AND WE
BELIEVE IT IS A NATURAL
EXTENSION OF PROP SIXTY THREE.
THE CITY FOR ALL ACT PASSED IN
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN GRANTING
THE DEPARTMENT INSPECTION
AUTHORITY OVER THOSE VENDORS
WHICH IT NOW HAS REGULATORY
AUTHORITY WHICH IS AN IMPORTANT
CONSIDERATION GIVEN THAT
CALIFORNIA DENTURES ARE STILL
PRESENT AND IN THE CITY
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU ARE THERE
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING REBEKAH MARKETS
REPRESENTING BRADY UNITED
AGAINST GUN VIOLENCE AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
GORE WATCH ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION GOING TWICE. OKAY I.
JUST WANNA MAKE SURE OF. ANY
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MUST COME UNDER THE OF
BECOME WATER NOW. THANK YOU
FOR- THIS BILL I HAVE TWO
QUESTIONS ACTUALLY ONE IS-
NONCOMPLIANCE A CIVIL PENALTY
OR CRIME. AND THE SECOND.
QUESTION AS NOTICE REQUIRED OR
DOES DEALER STATUS IMPLIED
CONSENT. SO IT DEPENDS ON THE
TYPE OF VIOLATION SO SOME
VIOLATIONS CAN BE A CIVIL FINE
BUT SOME DO RISE TO THE LEVEL
OF A MISDEMEANOR. OR. SEVEN THE
ANSWER YOUR QUESTIONS SOME ARE
INFRACTION SOMEWHERE
MISDEMEANORS SUMMER FELONY IT
DEPENDS ON THE SEVERITY OF THE
TYPE OF OFFENSE THAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT IN TERMS OF. THE
OFFENSE- IN TERMS OF DEALERS
ONE OF THE EXAMPLES THAT ARE
FREQUENTLY COMES UP IN TERMS OF
VIOLATIONS IS SIGNAGE. SO THE
LAWS IN THE STATE OF ALIFORNIA
REGARDING FIREARMS FREQUENTLY
CHECK JUST AND DEAL ARE
FREQUENTLY REQUIRED TO UPDATE
THEIR SIGNAGE IF THE TIME OF
INSPECTION THEY HAVEN'T UPDATED
THEIR SIGNAGE TO MATCH THE LAWS
EXACTLY. IT IS TECHNICALLY AN
INFRACTION. AND THE SECOND
QUESTION IF THERE IS A NOTICE
REQUIREMENT AT THERE IS NOT. SO
DO YOU RECESSES. DO AND THE
ANSWER THE FIRST QUESTION THAT
THERE IS NOT A NOTICE
REQUIREMENT I DO NOT KNOW THAT
IMPLIES CONSENT BUT I CAN GET
THAT. ANSWER TO YOU. THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FOR MANY
MEMBERS. YOU MAY CLOSE MUSLIM I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. WE'RE REALLY CLOSE TO
GETTING QUORUM SINCE WE DO-
HOOK WILL MOVE THIS SAID THE
CHAIRS RECOMMENDED AYE VOTE AND
WE NEED ONE MORE MEMBER TO GET
THERE. SO THANK YOU FOR COMING
DOWN THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
MADAM SECRETARY BEFORE THE
NEXT- AUTHOR COMES TO COULD
CALL THE ROLL. JONES SAWYER
HERE LACKEY BAUER-KAHAN. BAUER
K. HAND ARE YOU HERE DEEP.
KAMLAGER GABRIEL SANTIAGO WICKS.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT WE HAVE A
PROPOSED CONSENT CALENDAR OF
ITEM NUMBER THREE A. B. C.
NINETEEN SIXTY THREE TO CHILD
ABUSE OR NEGLECT MANDATED
REPORTERS AND ITEM NUMBER SIX
AB TWENTY ONE OH FIVE QUIRK
SILVA CRIMINAL PROCEDURE
COMPETENCE TO STAND TRIAL AND-
I'VE- I CANNOT GO. SECOND BY.
MS BAUER K. ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR JONES SAWYER HI JOHN
SIR HI LACKEY BARRICADE HAND
BARRICADE HAND I DEEP DEEP I
KAMLAGER KAMLAGER I GABRIEL.
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO HI WICKS.
IT'S SET COLLEGES DR YOU MAY
BEGIN MISS POWER. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS I AM
PRESENTING AB NINETEEN TWENTY
SEVEN ON BEHALF THAT HALF OF
THE FAMILY MEMBER
BOERNER HORVATH THIS MORNING.
AND THANK YOU. FOR THAT I'M AB
NINETEEN TWENTY SEVEN ESTABLISH
THE NARROW AMNESTY CLAUSE TO
ENCOURAGE VICTIMS AND WITNESSES
OF SEXUAL ASSAULT TO TESTIFY IN
COURT. SPECIFICALLY THE BILL
PROVIDES IMMUNITY TO THESE
VICTIMS AS WITNESSES FROM THE
CONSEQUENCES OF ALCOHOL OR DRUG
USE AT THE TIME OF
VICTIMIZATION. SEXUAL THE SPLIT
HAS BEEN HISTORICALLY UNDER
REPORTED CONSERVATIVE ESTIMATES
SUGGEST THAT 25% OF WOMEN
EXPERIENCE SEXUAL. INCLUDING
RAPE DURING THE LIFETIME.
STUDIES ALSO S. THAT HAVE OF
VICTIMS OF SEXUAL ASSAULTS WERE
CONSUMING ALCOHOL AT THE TIME
OF THE INCIDENT. FEAR OF
LIABILITY FOR THIS ILLEGAL
CONSUMPTION OF ALCOHOL AND
DRUGS CAN KEEP VICTIMS
REPORTING SEXUAL ASSAULT.
MULTIPLE REPORTS INCLUDING
REPORT BY THE WHITE HOUSE TASK
FORCE ON PROTECTING STUDENTS
FROM SEXUAL ASSAULT. CONFIRM
THAT AN AMNESTY CLAUSE CAN
IMPROVE REPORTING ON COLLEGE
CAMPUSES. HIGHER EDUCATION
INSTITUTIONS NATIONWIDE
INCLUDING THE UC HAVE ALREADY
IMPLEMENTED AMNESTY CAUSES THE
PROVIDE IMMUNITY FROM THE
CONSEQUENCES OF DRUG OR ALCOHOL
USE TO ENCOURAGE REPORTING. AB
NINETEEN TWENTY SEVEN SEEKS TO
EXTEND THE SAM'S ACOSTA ALL
SEXUAL ASSAULT VICTIMS AND
WITNESSES IN CALIFORNIA. AB
NINETEEN TWENTY SEVEN WOULD
SIMPLY FOR THE TESTIMONY OF THE
VICTIM OR WITNESS OF SEXUAL
ASSAULT ROUTED TO THE EAGER
LEGAL USE OF DRUGS AND A- CALL
FROM BEING USED AGAINST THEM IN
THIS. ACT SECURE SCHECK. RIVAS
THERE'S TO COME FORWARD. AS
BEING LIABLE FOR PROVIDE OF
UNDERAGE DRINKING OR USE.
WRITING TENS OF. OAKLAWN FOR.
CUTE THIS ASSAULT IN PUBLIC THE
OVERALL. AND HERE TO WITH ME
OUR PATCH ASPEN IS DEPUTY
DISTRICT ON HOW OF THE SAN
DIEGO JUST ATTORNEY'S OFFICE.
AND HOUGH TALLINN LAWYER IS
STUDENT DC SANTA BARBARA AND A
BOARD MEMBER OF STUDENTS
AGAINST SEXUAL ASSAULT. WANNA
MAKE SURE- WITH BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER JESSE GABRIEL
WHO'S HERE SUBSTITUTION FOR MR
QUIRK. WELL YOU MAY BEGIN. OKAY
GOOD MORNING WHAT'S YOUR FIRST
WISH WOULD BE ABOUT FIVE
MINUTES MY NAME IS PATRICK
ASPEN KNOWS I AM AT THE PGA TO
SEND YOU COUNTY DA'S OFFICE OF
THE CHIEF OF OUR SEX CRIMES AND
HUMAN TRAFFICKING DIVISION I'M
HERE TO I IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY SEVEN THE IDEA BEHIND
THIS LEGISLATION IS THAT WE
SHOULD NOT TREAT SEXUAL ASSAULT
VICTIMS IT'S CRIMINALS. WHEN
BUT THE GOAL OF THIS
LEGISLATION IS. PROMOTE NOT
ONLY PARTICIPATION THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM BUT ALSO TO
ENCOURAGE VICTIMS. OF SEXUAL
ASSAULT TO COME FORWARD AND
REPORT THE CRIME THIS IS AN
OFTEN. UNDER REPORTED CRIME
CRIMES OF SEXUAL ASSAULT. WE
KNOW THAT. THE PLAYERS INVOLVED
WITH THE PERPETRATORS THE
WITNESSES AND THE VICTIMS
OFTENTIMES THEIR- DRUG USE OF
PERHAPS ALCOHOL USE IT'S
AROUND- THE- COMMISSION THOSE
OFFENSES. THIS LEGISLATION IS
DESIGNED. TO PROVIDE WHAT WE
CALL AMNESTY. FOR OR IF USE
IMMUNITY FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS
BOTH WITNESSES AND VICTIMS TO
COME FORWARD AND TESTIFY TO
PARTICIPATE IN. THE UNDERLYING
PROCEEDINGS OF. THE SEXUAL.
CASE WHAT WE SEE CURRENTLY IS
THAT OFTEN TIMES THERE'S A LOT
OF ANXIETY. AND FEAR ABOUT
COMING FORWARD BECAUSE THE IDEA
IS. WITNESSES AND VICTIMS KNOW
THAT WHEN THEY TESTIFY IN THE
UNDERLYING SEXUAL ASSAULT. THE
KITCHEN. LIKELY TO BE ASKED
QUESTIONS ABOUT DRUG USE. OR
UNDER AGE ALCOHOL USE. AND THE
IDEA IS THOSE TRUTHFUL
TESTIMONY TRUTHFUL ANSWERS
QUESTION. MAY INCRIMINATE
HIMSELF. WHAT THIS BILL. YES
WITNESS IT GOOD SAMARITAN
WOULDN'T THIS AS WELL AS
VICTIMS THOSE THAT. BUT BY A
SURE THEM THAT THAT TO PROTEST
WILL NOT BE USED AGAINST THEM
IN THE IN SOME FUTURE
PROSECUTION CURRENTLY THERE IS
THAT A PROVISION THAT PROVIDES
IMMUNITY TO WITNESSES IN THE
SITUATION. HOWEVER IT'S IN
PERFECT IN THE SEXUAL ASSAULT
SITUATION BECAUSE- WHAT WOULD
REQUIRE THE TRIAL JUST TO DO IS
CALL A TIME OUT IN DEFENSE
ATTORNEY TO ADVISE. THE VICTIM
OF A SEXUAL ASSAULT IN THAT WAY
TREATS THEM LIKE LIKE A
CRIMINAL SO WE WOULD ASK THAT
SUPPORT VILLAGE FOR THIS
LEGISLATION WE WOULD URGE AND I
FELT THANK YOU FOR YOUR
ATTENTION. THANK YOU. MY NAME
IS TELLING WHERE AND I MEAN YOU
SEE. STUDENT AT. BOTH THE VICE
DIRECTOR STUDENTS CAN SEXUAL
ASSAULT AND AS AN ADVOCATE FOR
SURVIVORS OF SEXUAL VIOLENCE.
SO THE JUSTICE LAST MONTH SAYS
TO MEMBERS LAUNCHED A SEXUAL
ASSAULT CAMPUS CLIMATE SURVEY.
ON THE UCSD CAMPUS IN JUST ONE
WEEK RETAIN ONE THOUSAND FOUR
HUNDRED EIGHTEEN RESPONSES FROM
STUDENTS. AND THREE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY FIVE RESPONDENTS STATED
THAT THEY HAD BEEN SEXUALLY
ASSAULTED. MORE THAN HALF OF
THESE MEMBERS OR RESPONDENTS
WERE FRESHMEN OR SOPHOMORES.
AND A HUNDRED AND FORTY STATED
THEY'D VOLUNTARILY CONSUMED
ALCOHOL OR RECREATIONAL DRUGS
PRIOR TO THE ASSAULT. EVERY DAY
WE GET MORE RESPONSES IN EVERY
DAY THESE NUMBERS INCREASE. AND
THESE NUMBERS ARE THE PEOPLE
AROUND ME MY COLLEGE COMMUNITY
MY BEST FRIEND'S MY SORORITY
SISTERS MY CO WORKERS. EVEN
I'VE EXPERIENCED PEOPLE
THINKING THAT THEY'RE ENTITLED
TO MY BODY WITHOUT MY CONSENT
AFTER I'VE USED ALCOHOL AS A
MINOR. IN ONE OF THESE
EXPERIENCES THE PERPETRATOR
USED FOR PHYSICAL FORCE AND
THOUGHT IT WAS AN EASY TARGET
BECAUSE I'D CONSUMED ALCOHOL. I
NEVER REPORTED THESE
EXPERIENCES BECAUSE I WAS
SCARED OF REPRISAL ENABLING
MYSELF. WHEN A SURVIVOR REPORTS
OF SEXUAL ASSAULT ONE OF THE
FIRST QUESTIONS ARE ASKED IS
WHETHER ALCOHOL DRUGS WERE
INVOLVED. NOT ONLY DOES THIS
INVALIDATE THE SURVIVORS
EXPERIENCE BUT ALSO PRODUCES A
BARRIER AND DISCOMFORT IN
REPORTING. A SURVIVOR SHOULD
NEVER BE IN A POSITION WHERE
FEAR RETALIATION DISCOURAGES
THEIR ENGAGEMENT WITH THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM.
ALLOWING SURVIVORS TESTIMONY OF
UNLAWFULLY CONSUMING ALCOHOL
AND- RECREATIONAL DRUGS TO BE
USED IN CRIMINAL PROCEDURES
AGAINST THEM TO PUT TO A- VOTE
AGAINST THEM IS CONTRARY AND
CONTRADICTORY TO THE MISSION OF
OUR CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM.
WHEN THAT AIM TO PROTECT
SURVIVORS AND PENALIZE
PERPETRATORS WHO COMMIT THESE
VULGAR OFFENSES. WE ARE THE
SYSTEM ARE FAILING SURVIVORS BY
PRODUCING AN UNSAFE AND
INTIMIDATING REPORTING PROCESS
AB NINETEEN TWENTY SEVEN IS
NECESSARY AND ENSURING
SURVIVORS RATES ARE UP HELD.
AND THAT SURVIVORS CANNOT BE
UNJUSTLY PERSECUTED FOR
REPORTING THEIR EXPERIENCE
THANK. THANK YOU OTHER ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. OF
JOHN LEVEL ON BEHALF OF THE-
CALIFORNIA COLLEGE AND
UNIVERSITY POLICE CHIEFS.
ASSOCIATION SEXUAL ASSAULTS ARE
ONE OF THE CATEGORIES OF CRIMES
THAT TAKE PLACE AYE
DISPROPORTIONATELY I'M SORRY SO
LEVEL IS ALL RIGHT NAME AN
ORGANIZATION STRONGLY SUPPORT
THE BILL GOOD SENSE BILL. THANK
YOU. MORE ENGLISH GERMAN
MEMBERS LARRY MORSE- CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION
SPONSOR AND IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THE BILL. MICHELLE THOMAS
SHOP REPRESENTING ALAMEDA
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY NEEDS
YOUR MOLLY WERE ALSO CO
SPONSORS OF THIS BILL THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING EVERYONE JOHN
FAMILY REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION AGAINST
SEXUAL ASSAULT SPEAKING IN FULL
SUPPORT THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING
THIS ENABLES OTHERS ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIA CIVIL LIBERTIES
ADVOCACY AND WE'RE IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL. THANK YOU. ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. HI GOOD MORNING.
GOOD. THE. MARGOT GEORGE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION OF FIRST
I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR IN
THE COMMITTEE OF FOR THE
AMENDMENT TO A. B. NINETEEN
TWENTY SEVEN ACTING AT TO
FELONIES ONLY UNFORTUNATELY
WILL MISS STILL OPPOSE- THIS
BILL UNLESS IT'S AMENDED TO
PROTECT THE CONST THE
CONSTITUTION THAT'S
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO CROSS
EXAMINE AND CONFRONT. AND FIRST
I WANT TO SAY THAT THIS BILL
WILL NOT STOP RAPE CULTURE AND
SECONDLY. THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION DOESN'T
THINK THAT ANYONE SHOULD BE
PROSECUTED FOR ALCOHOL AND DRUG
OFFENSES SO WE'RE NOT AGAINST
EXPANDING THE PROTECTION OF NO
PROSECUTION WHAT WE ARE
AGAINST. IS THE USE OF THE
COMPELLED TESTIMONY WITHOUT THE
DEFENDANT'S RIGHT TO CROSS
AMENDMENT WE'RE ASKING FOR
WOULD SAY THAT THIS-
LEGISLATIVE IMMUNITY WOULD NOT
LIMIT. QUESTIONING BY THE
DEFENDANT OF THE VICTIM OR THE
WITNESS- AND FOR THE MORE THAT
THE IMMUNITY- WOULD BE
ADMISSIBLE TO THE SAME EXTENT
THAT ANY OTHER GRANT OF
IMMUNITY WOULD BE. UNDER
EXISTING LAW. A WITNESS CAN BE
CROSS EXAMINED ABOUT ANY GRANT
OF IMMUNITY WHETHER OR NOT IT
IS A GRANT THAT COMES- THROUGH
THE COURT PROCEDURE. THAT THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY DESCRIBED OR
IF IT'S JUST AN ORAL PROMISE BY
THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY OR THE
POLICE THAT THE PERSON WILL NOT
BE PROSECUTED AND THAT IS A
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT THAT HAS
BEEN REPEATEDLY UP HELD BY BOTH
FEDERAL IN CALIFORNIA COURTS.
IN FACT IT'S REVERSIBLE ERROR
NOT TO READ ALOUD THE DEFENDANT
CROSS EXAMINE THE WITNESS ABOUT
ANY BARGAIN THEY'VE MADE WITH
THE GOVERNMENT. AB NINETEEN
TWENTY SEVEN SEEKS TO SHIELD
THE VICTIM OR WITNESS FROM THAT
CROSS EXAMINATION BY MAKING IT
A LEGISLATIVE GRANT OF IMMUNITY
AND THAT'S NOTA VERY BROAD
GRANT OF IMMUNITY IT'S ONLY FOR
THEIR TESTIMONY THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY CAN AN- CURRENTLY
STILL WISHES TO HAVE UP THE
THREAT OF PROSECUTION HOLDING
OVER THE WITNESS TO COMPEL.
THEIR COOPERATION AND TESTIMONY
BY THREATENING TO PROSECUTE
THEM FOR EITHER THE DRUG OR
ALCOHOL OFFENSE WHILE AT THE
SAME TIME ABROGATING THE
DEFENDANT'S RIGHT TO CROSS
EXAMINE. UNDER EXISTING LAW
PROSECUTORS CAN ALREADY TELL
THE VICTIM OR WITNESS DON'T
WORRY WE'RE NOT GOING TO
PROSECUTE YOU FOR THAT WE'RE
NOT GOING TO FILE CHARGES. AND
IF THEY DO FILE CHARGES THEN
THEY CAN- ASKS FOR STATUTORY
GRANT OF IMMUNITY IT IS NOT
SOMETHING THE DEFENSE DOESN'T
HAVE THE SAME RIGHT TO GO TO
COURT AND ASK OR STATUTORY
GRANT OF IMMUNITY FOR DEFENSE
WITNESS. SO BASICALLY THE AB
NINETEEN TWENTY SEVEN SIX TO
ABROGATE THE DEFENDANT'S RIGHT
TO CROSS EXAMINE. BY CLICKING
THE PROSECUTION WITNESS IN THIS
LEGISLATIVE IMMUNITY WHILE
ALLOWING THE PROSECUTOR TO
COMPEL THE WITNESSES
COOPERATION. FOR THOSE REASONS
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR NO
VOTE AND LESS IT' AMENDED TO
PROTECT THE DEFENDANT'S RIGHT
TO CROSS EXAMINE THANK YOU
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION. MORNING MR CHAIR
MEMBERS MIGHT THE DOCTOR OFF ON
BEHALF OF THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA WE ARE ALSO
REGRETFULLY IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL- AND APOLOGIZE FOR
GETTING OUR LETTER IN LATER
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. OF BRING
IT BACK TO COMMITTEE MEMBERS OF
ANY QUESTIONS. MISS COLORADO
KAMLAGER SO I WANT TO THANK YOU
MISS. MAYOR HORVATH GLASS BRING
HER QUE AND- OUR CAN FOR-
REPRESENTING OUR GOOD FRIEND-
FROM ANTHONY THIS I
UNFORTUNATELY WILL NOT BE ABLE
TO VOTE ON THIS BILL RIGHT NOW-
BECAUSE OF A NUMBER OF CONCERNS
THAT WERE RAISED BY- BOTH THE
ACLU. AND THE PUBLIC DEFENDER'S
ASSOCIATION- SEXUAL ASSAULT IS
VERY REAL ON CAMPUSES I THINK
ANYONE WHO'S SEEN THE MOVIE THE
HUNTING GROUND KNOWS. THAT
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES NEED
TO UP THEIR GAME WITH REGARDS
TO POLICIES AND PROCEDURES AND
ENFORCEMENT AND RECOGNIZE THE
BOX THAT IS IN HERE IN A LOT
OF- CAMPUS CULTURE MOSTLY
BECAUSE OF THE REVENUE THAT'S
GENERATED FROM SO MANY OF OUR-
A PROGRAMS THAT ARE ON- THOSE
CAMPUSES. AND FOCUSING TO GET
WITH THE PROGRAM HAVING SAID
THAT I THINK THERE'S A
DIFFERENCE. BETWEEN THE CAMPUS
CULTURE AND WHAT HAPPENS
THROUGH OUR PENAL CODE YOU KNOW
I REALLY SEE THIS AS A SLIPPERY
SLOPE AND UNNECESSARY BECAUSE.
YOUR DISPOSAL YOU HAVE PENAL
CODE TWO TWENTY YOU HAVE PENAL
CODE. TWO SIXTY ONE TWO EIGHTY
NINE TWO FORTY THREE- YOU
ALREADY HAVE DISCRETION TO
OFFER IMMUNITY IF YOU WANT AND
SO TO YOUR POINT YOU SAID YOU
YOU YOU DON'T NEED TO AND YOU
SHOULDN'T BE REATING SEXUAL
ASSAULT VICTIMS AS CRIMINALS.
YOU SHOULDN'T BE DOING THAT
ANYWAY THAT HAS NOTHING TO DO
WITH LACK OF LAW IT HAS A LOT
MORE TO DO WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT
CULTURE AND HOW YOU TREAT FOLKS
TO COME FORWARD- THERE IS A
CHALLENGE THAT I SEE RIGHT NOW
AND MAYBE THEY CAN GET AMENDED.
AROUND EXCLUDING EVIDENCE MY
MIND I DON'T SEE HOW THIS DOES
NOT CONFLICT WITH THE
PROSECUTOR AFFIRMATIVE DUTY PER
BRADY. AND WHEN YOU'RE LOWERING
THE BAR FOR CONVICTION YOU'RE
ALSO LOWERING THE BAR FOR DUE
PROCESS I HAVE SOME VERY REAL
QUICK. ABOUT HOW MUCH. I
INTOXICANT INTERLACED WITH THE
EVENT I THINK IS VERY REAL SO
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN THE
SUBSTANCES ARE CONSENSUALLY
SHARED HOW DO YOU PROCEED WHEN
A VICTIM HAS PRIORS WHAT IF THE
VICTIM HAS SUPPLIED THE DRUGS.
IS THE TYPE OR AMOUNT OF
SUBSTANCE DOES THAT MAKE A
DIFFERENCE IN THIS SCENARIO I
WOULD ARGUE THAT IF YOU HAVE
SOMEONE WHO'S BEEN SUPPLYING.
YOU KNOW FENTANYL TONS AND TONS
OF SENTINEL WHICH IS KILLING
PEOPLE. THAT ACTUALLY IS VERY
REAL IN A CONVERSATION ABOUT
CRIMINAL ACTIVITY IT HAS
ABSOLUTELY NOTHING TO DO WITH
SEXUAL ASSAULT. IN THE IMMUNITY
THAT YOU COULD OFFER FOR THAT
YOU ALREADY HAVE AT YOUR
DISPOSAL- BUT IT PROVIDES US A
VERY SLIPPERY SLOPE. TWO
EXCLUDING EVIDENCE AND THEN HOW
IS THAT SHARED IN TERMS OF JURY
DESCRIBE DISK INSTRUCTIONS ARE
YOU THEN MAKING SURE THAT
YOU'RE TELLING THAT TO THE JURY
WE ARE EXCLUDING ALL OF THIS
EVIDENCE THAT COULD BE
RELEVANT. SO I WANT TO SUPPORT
THE WOMEN AND THE MEN WHO ARE
SEXUALLY ASSAULTED ON CAMPUS I
WANT TO SUPPORT. MEN AND WOMEN
WHO ARE SEXUALLY ASSAULTED YOU
KNOW IN THE WORLD AND I THINK
THAT WE HAVE THE TOOLS AT OUR
DISPOSAL THROUGH A NUMBER OF
SECTIONS IN THE PENAL CODE. TO
DO THAT- AND SO WITH THAT I
JUST WANTED TO SHARE MY
RESERVATIONS AND CONCERNS AND
HOPE THAT I WILL BE ABLE TO
SUPPORT THIS WHEN IT COMES TO
THE FLOOR IF THERE AMENDMENTS
ARE- YOU KNOW ADOPTED. THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR TALKING TO
CHAIR AND.OF. BUT I KNOW ANY
OTHER MEMBERS THAT HAVE
QUESTIONS AND BEFORE I. AND I
KNOW OF THE AUTHORS NOT THERE
AND AT NIGHT HERE OB DID. DO
YOU WANT TO ADDRESS SOME OF
THAT RIGHT NOW OR HAVE SOME OF
THE WITNESSES IMPRESSIVE HOW
WOULD YOU LIKE TO HANDLE YES
I'D LOVE TO TURN OVER TO THE
WITNESS TO ANSWER SOME OF THOSE
QUESTIONS. A PARENT THEIR
QUESTIONS. EIGHT SHOULD YES
THIRTY CHAIR THANK YOU TALK TO
HIM. AND I WROTE DOWN THE
NUMBER CONCERNS I'M HAPPY TO
DROP ONE OF THE MAIN CONCERNS
WAS THE NOTION THAT THIS BILL
EXCLUDES EVIDENCE AND LET ME BE
CLEAR THERE IS USE IMMUNITY AND
THEN THERE'S TRANSACTIONAL BUT
LET ME. SPECIFICALLY THE
QUESTION BUT EXCLUDING EVIDENCE
IN THE UNDERLYING. SEXUAL
ASSAULT PROSECUTION. THE USE OF
ALCOHOL BY THE COMPLAINING
WITNESS BY THE VICTIM FOR OR
ILLEGAL DRUGS THAT WOULD NOT BE
EXCLUDED THE BILL DOES NOT
IMPACT THAT AT ALL WHAT HAPPENS
IS THE DEFENSE ATTORNEY. FOR
THE ACCUSED WOULD BE ABLE TO
CROSS EXAMINE THE VICTIM AND
ASK THOSE QUESTIONS ELICIT THAT
EVIDENCE SO THAT THE JURY COULD
HEAR THE FACT FINDER COULD HURT
HERE THE ONLY LIMITATION ON
ADMISSIBILITY. OF EVIDENCE
WOULD BE IF. THAT VICTIM OR
THAT TESTIFYING WITNESS WAS
GOING TO BE PROSECUTED AGAIN IN
A SEPARATE CASE. FOR USE OF
ALCOHOL FOR POSSESSION OF
ALCOHOL FOR USE OF A CONTROLLED
SUBSTANCE FOR MAP POSSESSION OF
A CONTROLLED SUBSTANCE. THEN IN
THAT STEP CASE THE TESTIMONY
THAT THE VICTIM WHAT THE
WITNESS GAVE AND THE UNDERLYING
SEX CRIMES CASE THAT TESTIMONY
COULD NOT BE USED TO BUILD A
PROSECUTION IN A SEPARATE CASE.
AGAINST THAT VICTIM WE'RE GOOD
SAMARITAN WITNESS YOU CAME FOR
SO I THINK THERE'S A MIS
UNDERSTANDING OF. THE
ADMISSIBILITY HOW MUCH LIMIT
IT'S LIMITED- ONLY IN THE EVENT
OF A FUTURE PROSECUTION SO I
THINK THAT ADDRESSES ONE
CONCERN IS THAT THE A SIMPLE
PERSON MAY HAVE RAISED.
CONCERNS TO ADDRESS THE
SITUATION WELL. THERE HAS TO BE
IN ON THE ENDING OF THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN USE
IMMUNITY. ENTRANCE CHANNEL ME.
TRêN. I WHERE. THE THERE'S A
NEW GIVEN FOR THE- PROCESS. OF
THAT. SO IN THE EXAMPLE ASK
WHAT ABOUT THAT NO WHAT ABOUT
IF A RAPE VICTIM WAS SUPPLYING
FAT NOW. AND DURING THE
UNDERLYING SEX CRIMES
PROSECUTION THAT RAPE VICTIM
ADMITTED THAT THERE WAS FAT AND
ALL PROVIDED THAT WAS THE
SUBJECT OF THE SEXUAL ASSAULT.
WELL IN THAT CASE. ONLY IF LAW
ENFORCEMENT WAS TO INDEPENDENT
BE ABLE TO BUILD A CASE AGAINST
VICTIM FOR FAT NO USE OR- OR
SALES OR IN SOME WAY. THAT
PROSECUTION COULD GO FORWARD
ALL THIS LEGISLATION SAYS IS IN
THE EVENT WHEN YOU'RE
PROSECUTING THE SEX CRIMES. IF
THE TRUTHFUL TESTIMONY FROM
THAT DATA MORE YES- AN- IMAGE
USE OF THAT IN ALL OR WHATEVER
LSD OR METHAMPHETAMINE. YOU
CANNOT USE THAT TESTIMONY IN
THE SEXUAL ASSAULT PROSECUTION
FOR SOME SET A SUBSEQUENT
FEDERAL PROSECUTION SO I THINK.
THAT UNDERSTANDING OF THE ENTRY
EXACT. A I THINK THAT THOSE
CONCERNS AND HOPEFULLY OUR
ALLIED. THERE WAS THIS OTHER
REFERENCE WELL THE PROSECUTION
HAS PLENTY OF THOSE THEY CAN
PROMISE THE WITNESS. THEY'RE.
NOT GONNA BE PROCESS. FOR DRUG
USE WELL WE HAVE MOVED AWAY
FROM THE THAT IS A CONCEPT OF
HIP IMMUNITY IDEA THAT THE DA
IS ENGAGING IN SECRET DEALS
WITH THE AT LAW ENFORCEMENT IS
ENGAGING IN SECRET DEALS WITH
THE WITNESS. THAT DES NOT
HAPPEN WE MOVED AWAY FROM THAT
WE HAVE A FORMAL PROCESS SO
THAT EVERYTHING IS TRANSPARENT
AND SO THIS THIS NOTION OF THE
PA COULD USE. INFORMAL PROMISES
PROMISES AND HIP POCKET
IMMUNITY THAT WOULD BE-
ANATHEMA TO A PROSECUTOR IN THE
MODERN DAY THAT IS SOMETHING WE
WOULDN'T DO THAT IS SOMETHING
WE DON'T WANT OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS. GOING IN
TELLING WITNESSES. PRIVATELY
HEY DON'T WORRY ABOUT IT YOU'RE
NOT BE PROSECUTED FOR YOUR DRUG
USE OF. ALCOHOL USE AND SO
THERE IS A MOVEMENT AWAY FROM
THAT. IN FACT THE ONLY FORMAL
PROCESSES IN THIRTEEN TWENTY
FOUR OF THE PENAL CODE. WHAT
THE JUDGE WOULD HAVE TO COMPEL
THE WITNESS TO TESTIFY THE
REASON WHY THIS IS PROBLEMATIC
IN A SEX CRIMES PROSECUTION IS
BECAUSE OF PENAL CODE SECTION
SIX EIGHTY POINT TWO. IT WAS
ABOUT THREE YEARS AGO THAT THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED SIX EIGHTY
POINT TWO. SIXTEEN POINT TWO
SAYS. THAT POLICE OFFICERS AND
NURSES WHEN THEY FIRST COME IN
CONTACT WITH A SEX CRIME VICTIM
HAVE TO GIVE A CARD WITH ALL
THEIR LEGAL RIGHTS. ONE OF
THOSE LEGAL RIGHTS IS. THAT A
YOU DO NOT HAVE TO PARTICIPATE
IN THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE-
PROCESS. THAT IS INCONSISTENT
WITH MY VICTIM LESS POTENTIAL
CRIMINAL LIABILITY WAS IN THE
PROCESS AND HAS TO GO TO. THE
TWENTY FOUR MINUTE PROCESS. THE
ONLY WAY TO FORMALLY PROVIDE
NEARLY AS WITH A- COMPACT AND
THE TYPE OF TESTIFIED IN SO
THAT'S VERY INCONSISTENT. WITH
THE RIGHTS THAT HE- GIVE OUR
VICTIMS INTO THE SIX EIGHTY TWO
POINT CAR POINT TWO CARD. THAT
DOES THAT WAS- THE STATE POLICY
AND THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. SO
I HOPE I ADDRESSED ALL OF THE
CONCERNS IF THERE WAS SOME OF
THE CONCERNS THAT I DIDN'T I
CERTAINLY HAVE RESPONSE THEM I
KNOW THEY WERE COMING COMING
FAST AND FURIOUS THE CHAIR HAS
ANY FURTHER CONCERNS. AT
PRESENT I. DO THAT. AND MEASURE
BY TAKE THAT AGE YOU'RE CLOSING
OR PARTY OR THE FOUR DIGIT
WHERE THERE THERE ARE NO OTHER
QUESTIONS ON YOUR- I WAS. NOT
DISS HER THIS IS PART OF THE
CLOSING RIGHT THE CLOTHING. I
AM SO I JUST WANT TO SAY THAT I
AGREE WITH AND THE PUBLIC
DEFENDER'S THAT THIS ONE STOP
RAPE CULTURE I THINK WE ALL
KNOW THAT I DON'T THINK THE
PROPONENTS ARE AT SAYING IT
WELL BUT THERE'S NO QUESTION
THAT ON COLLEGE CAMPUSES MANY
OF WHICH- MANY OF US HAVE BEEN
WORKING ON COLLEGE CAMPUSES AND
WE KNOW WHAT THIS. IS NO THE
THING WOMEN A SENSE THAT THEY
WILL BE SAFE IN THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM MAKE AND THEY'RE
NOT COMPLETELY SAFE IF THEY'VE
BEEN A WRONGDOER IN OTHER WAYS
BUT THE SMALL PIECE OF SECURITY
WILL HOPEFULLY. CHANGE THAT
CALL IN SMALLEST. BIT SO THAT
MORE VICTIMS WILL COME FORWARD
AND FEEL SAFE IN THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM. WITH THAT I
WILL ASK YOU FOR YOUR EITHER.
IN THE CHAIRS. RECOMMENDED I.
IS REALLY BASED ON. THE OFFICE-
I REALLY DO BELIEVE TE AUTHOR.
WILL WORK. WITH THE OPPOSITION.
ON THE NIGHT IN OPPOSITION YOUR-
YOUR- I WILL SAY I. A LESS I
MEANT IT- IF WE CAN GET TO THAT
SWEET SPOT- WHICH I THINK AS WE
MOVE FORWARD WE CAN- WITH
FURTHER DIALOGUE BECAUSE IT'S A-
IT'S A IT'S A LOT. AND AT AND
IF WE CAN GET THROUGH WHERE
WHICH OF I THINK WE ALL WANT TO
GET TO THE SAME PLACE. ON BOTH
SIDES AND IF WE CONTINUE TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE TRYING TO
GET TO THAT TARGET. INSTEAD OF
MAYBE. DISCUSSING THAT MY WAY
VERSUS YOUR WAY BUT WE AL WANT
TO MAKE SURE. PEOPLE ARE SAFE
ON CAMPUSES AND- RAPE VICTIMS-
THE BEST WE CAN GET WE CAN
PROTECT THEM. AND SO AS CHAIR
RECOMMENDED AND I VOTE WE HAD A
MOTION AND A SECOND. THEY CALL
THE ROLL. I'M AB NINETEEN
TWENTY SEVEN THE MOTION IS TO
PASS JONES SAWYER HI JONES
SAWYER AYE LACKEY. BARRICADE
HAN BARRICADE HAND I DEEP. DEEP
I KAMLAGER. KAMLAGER NOT VOTING.
GABRIEL GABRIEL AYE SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO AYE WICKS. THAT
MEASURE PASSES THANK YOU AND
THANK YOU TO EACH SIDE FOR
BEING HERE TODAY. AND I WILL
TAKE UP THE MEASURES. THAT WE
HEARD. AS A SUBCOMMITTEE MISSED
DID. THIS COME LONGER DOVE. TO
SHE VOTE ON ALL THESE. THE
ONLY. ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
LACKEY GABRIEL. GABRIEL I WICKS.
ITEM NUMBER ONE HAS JUST BEEN
DISPENSED WITH. ITEM NUMBER TWO
AB NINETEEN THIRTY SIX
RODRIGUEZ THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
IS THERE A MOTION. UP TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE EXCUSE
ME. JONES SAWYER JOHN SIR I
LACKEY POWER CAN BARRICADE HAD
HI DEEP DEEP I KAMLAGER
KAMLAGER I GABRIEL GABRIEL AYE
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO AYE WICKS.
ITEM NUMBER THREE WAS ON
CONSENT. ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB
TWENTY FOURTEEN. THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED TO THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE IS THERE A MOTION.
JONES SAWYER JONES SAWYER AYE
LACKEY BARRICADE HAN BARRICADE
HAD AYE DEEP. DEEP I KAMLAGER
KAMLAGER HI GABRIEL GABRIEL AYE
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO AYE WICKS.
ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB TWENTY
SIXTY ONE THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
IS THERE A MOTION. JONES SAWYER
DANSER I LACKEY. BARRICADE HAN
BARKING HAD HI DEEP DEEP I
KAMLAGER KAMLAGER HI GABRIEL
GABRIEL AYE SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO
I WICKS THAT MOTION THAT
MEASURE PASSES ITEM NUMBER SIX
WAS ON CONSENT. THANK YOU AND
THAT ENDS THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC SAFETY.